[Musique]
bienvenue à tous ravis de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui un vent high tech souffle
sur paris saclay tv on vous dit tout du
projet iseult lancé par le cea projet
qui a permis la création d'un aimant
unique au monde par sa taille par sa
puissance
eelv a révolutionné l'imagerie par
résonance magnétique
il va explorer cette zone encore inconnu
de notre cerveau ça ressemble à une
bibliothèque mais ce n'est pas une
bibliothèque c'est encore mieux
un learning center va ouvrir ses portes
dans le quartier du moulon un lieu
numérique ouvert à tous et qui dit
chantier d'iter excavés que faire des
déblais le pea ps se lance dans une
expérimentation ou vous en dit plus dans
un instant enfin il fallait une
signature pour promouvoir votre
territoire à travers le monde un grand
concours a été lancé
vous allez découvrir les six lauréats et
leurs slogans
enfin votre agenda ce sera à la fin de
cette émission
le projet iseult il a été lancé il ya
quinze ans maintenant par le cea il
s'agissait de construire léman le plus
puissant au monde un aimant qui va
révolutionner l'imagerie par résonance
magnétique cette machine a été créée
convoyer ici à neurospin elle va
permettre d'explorer une zone encore
très mystérieuse notre cerveau
[Musique]
vous avez ici les moïses holt qui est la
partie centrale de l'irm de recherche
zulte qui va être installé à neurospin
donc c'est un projet qui a été lancé il
ya une quinzaine d'années pour délivrer
sur le site de neurospin léman le plus
puissant au monde
donc après la mise en fonctionnement de
cette irm unique nous allons pouvoir
explorer le cerveau avec une résolution
spatiale très impressionnant puisque par
rapport aux irm actuelles qui permettent
de voir le cerveau avec une résolution
de l'ordre d'un grain de riz nous allons
pouvoir descendre à l'échelle de
quelques cheveux d'épaisseur donc cela
va nous permettre de mieux comprendre
tous les mécanismes de fonctionnement du
cerveau donc aussi bien le cerveau sain
donc en particulier à neurospin ya déjà
beaucoup d'étude sur le vieillissement
du cerveau donc ça mais également bien
sûr de nous intéresser au développement
des pathologies à leurs différents
mécanismes
nous allons également travailler côté
plus aux neurosciences à l'exploration
des fonctions cognitives avec une
également une meilleure résolution
spatiale donc avec cet élément nouveau
avons donc compléter le panel des irm
déjà disponibles et franchir un pas
important donc de faire une meilleure
résolution spatiale pour pousser dans
toutes ses recherches vers une
exploration à part plus fine du cerveau
de son fonctionnement et des pathologies
associées
la totalité du projet ses 15 ans avec en
gros une première phase de 6 7 ans de
r&d pour développer tous les concepts
ensuite une recherche une partie
recherche de financement est ensuite un
peu plus de six ans pour la fabrication
complète de cet objet unique
[Musique]
dont clément a été livré c'est une étape
importante dans le projet mais c'est
loin d'être la fin l'on va transférer
dans quelques jours les membres
intérieur de l'arche mais il va falloir
encore près d'un an pour mettre tout en
place
montez le champ magnétique à 11,7 tesla
et ensuite il faudra plus d'un an pour
transformer cet aimant on a un imageur
complet c'est-à-dire un système capable
de faire des images très précises du
cerveau
autre projet ambitieux mené sur le
territoire le learning center à concept
venu des pays anglo saxons cette
bibliothèque high tech ouvrira ses
portes en 2020 dans le quartier du
moulleau ce sera un lieu ouvert à tous
julien tempéré et le chef de projet il
nous en dit plus
[Musique]
le projet learning center de
l'université paris saclay c'est un
projet qui a vu le jour dès le début du
projet campus c'est un bâtiment qui doit
se conclure ce le plateau de moulon
pourquoi on dit pas bibliothèque mais
andy learning center c'est parce qu'il
va également accueillir la diagonale
paris saclay qui est la dimension
science et société de l'université
donc ce sera un lieu d'exposition grand
public c'est un lieu numérique
c'est un lieu qui me fera la part belle
aussi à toutes les tentatives autour du
numérique que ce soit celle des start up
par exemple qui pourront présenter au
sein de ce learning center ce qu'elles
font là aussi au grand public mais
également donc des contenus numériques
et c'est un lieu particulier parce que
c'est un lieu ouvert à tous tout le
monde pourra s'y rencontrer aussi bien
les étudiants de toutes les écoles et
universités
les chercheurs des organismes de
recherche et là aussi de tous les
laboratoires de l'université mais
également les gens des entreprises aux
alentours qui pourront peut-être être
intéressé par l'université donc c'est un
projet qui aura trois grands espaces
n'est ce pas ce qu'on appelle le forum
avec un auditorium une brasserie pour
l'aspect convivialité rencontre est donc
un patio pour aussi donc il donnera un
côté extérieur au bâtiment
ce forum accueillera les expositions et
les autres événements ensuite il ya un
plateau projet où il y aura des salles
de travail en groupes de toutes
dimensions de quatre personnes jusqu'à
64 personnes avec un open space
également est en fait donc le coeur du
bâtiment ce tout en haut du bâtiment ce
sera le plateau silence qu'on appelait
c'est à dire le travail individuel avec
des collections qu'elle soit
électronique ou physique et il dominera
le bâtiment et donnera là aussi sur un
belvédère qui aura vu sur l'ensemble du
quartier de moulins et dominera aussi le
métro de la ligne 10 8 donc ces trois
espaces communiquant autour de services
partagés une programmation commune et
donneront accès seront accessibles pour
l'ensemble de l'université paris saclay
donc ce projet nous le construisons
c'est une maîtrise orages de
l'université paris saclay nous sommes
accompagnés par l'établissement public
d'aménagement paris saclay et donc nous
sommes en phase d'étude actuellement en
travaillant sur les plans ensemble avec
notre architecte beaudoin architecture
et son partenaire mgm arquitectos les
architectes espagnols et la livraison
est prévue pour 2020
tous ces chantiers en train d excavation
alors que faire des déblais que vous
voyez juste derrière moi les jetez vous
n'y pensez pas le pps innove et décide
de réutiliser ces sols en les rendant
fertile pour l'aménagement paysager de
la zac
une expérimentation est en cours tout de
suite les précisions d'antoine des mots
lien il est le chef de projet
[Musique]
à paris saclay travaille sur deux
aspects des sols c'est à dire dans tout
les sens dans tous les sols qui sont
excavés aucun n'est sorti de la zac est
réutilisé pour l'ensemble des espaces
publics donc une partie est stockée sur
le sur le territoire des actes
directement donc en deux parties la
partie seul plutôt fertile donc les
premiers mètres et la partie sol stérile
donc les mails et mettre plus profond
tout ce qui est les seuls plus profond
on utilise directement les terres
fertiles pour faire des aménagements
paysagers essentiellement et tout ce qui
est terres stériles pour faire des
structures de chaussée où des structures
de trottoirs à une deuxième approche
qu'on a adopté dernièrement c'est
essayer justement de faire que ses
seules stérile deviennent fertile en
gros pouvoir créer des soldes fertile
appartient des sols plus profond des
limons profond donc c'est ce qu'on
réalise sur la plateforme qui est
derrière moi l'enrichissement de limos
conteste sur cette plateforme c'est la
capacité des limons stérile avec de la
matière organique en fait du compost ou
tout simplement mélangé la capacité car
à cette terre à 7 à devenir fertile et
donc à engendrer la croissance des
arbres que vous voyez derrière moi donc
cette plateforme elle permet de comparer
une croissance dans un sol stériles un
lit mais stérile avec nos limon laquelle
on a ajouté du compost
le but final de cette expérimentation
c'est à partir de tous les limons qu'on
a qu'on a extrait qu'on a en grande
quantité et qu'on aura sûrement quantité
surnuméraires par rapport à tous les
espaces publics on a créé ce sera de
créer des terres fertiles qu'on pourra
réutiliser pour autre chose que ce
soient les aménagements paysagers de la
zac ou éventuellement les aménagements
paysagers ou les espaces verts qui peut
y avoir à l'extérieur de la zac qui sera
vraiment dans un second temps vraiment
le premier temps c'est d'avoir
suffisamment de terre végétale de terres
fertiles pour pouvoir aménager notre
noack l'expérimentation va se dérouler
entre 18 mois et deux ans avec des
premiers résultats au bout d'un an
donc sachant que ça a commencé là
dernièrement on peut compter vraiment un
an à partir de maintenant donc début
d'été 2018 on aura des premiers
résultats et ensuite pour la gestion des
terres de manière générale ça va venir
au fur et à mesure du développement des
actes donc clairement ce sera quelque
chose s'il sera en rien au développement
des axes si le planning des ac dépasse
2020 2021 2022
à quelque part la gestion des terres
suivra aussi ce planning se plaignent
enfin il fallait trouver une signature
pour paris saclay un slogan pour
promouvoir votre territoire à travers le
monde un grand concours a été lancé des
centaines de personnes y ont participé
nous avons rencontré les six lauréats
ils ont accepté de pitch est pour vous
leur slogan à vous de voir celui que
vous préférez
[Musique]
mon slogan c'est paris saclay il était
une fois l'innovation pour évoquer le
domaine des comptes en fait des belles
histoires qui font rêver qui inspire des
gens l'idée de il était une fois
l'innovation c'est un appel à
l'innovation a osé bouger l'ordre établi
à de faire parler ça qui est vraiment un
levier pour tous ceux qui veulent agir
[Musique]
en
paris saclay innovant ensemble au
service du vivant c'est le
c'est devant que j'ai choisi pourquoi
parce que je suis convaincu qu il est
possible d'allier modernité évolutions
et innovations et humanisme
[Musique]
mon slogan c'est paris saclay une
ovation sur un plateau j'ai choisi ce
slogan parce que pour moi le plateau de
saclay est un lieu où neuf où on se
rassemble et où on partage des idées
pour l'innovation
[Musique]
ouais
mon slogan ne s'est pas hissé clefe r d
la france sa figuration sap table du
monde parce que je suis convaincu
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai failli saclay des
talents et des ressources pour faire de
la france le plus grand cube et heures
de surf mondial
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
paris saclay innovation playground parce
que l'innovation est une passion et que
sans jeu il n'y a pas de passion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant notre agenda à ne surtout
pas rater dans les semaines à venir
l'anniversaire du proto 204 et
l'inauguration du proto bus on vous en a
beaucoup parlé dans paris saclay tv et
bien ce sera le 30 mai au proto 204 le
proto bus aux futures enseignes de la
ville est là ça sera du 8 au 10 juin
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui nous
reviendrons sur ces événements bien sûr
dans notre prochain numéro
mais d'ici là restez informés grâce à
notre site eps.fr merci de votre
attention et à très vite
[Musique]